foreign
[Music]
let's go
let's see if we get white we do against
ayoi from Greece
all right let's see what we get in the
opening we go E4
excellent I was selfishly hoping
we would get an elephant and we do
E6 okay so E6 is a second tier move
it is considered by many to be sort of
the third best option I would say by
most uh to be the third best option
after the two main moves of course D5 is
one and Knight F6 is the other
and E6 has an interesting property in
that
after we play the move d4 which is
obviously White's next move black can
allow a transposition to an advanced
French like if we play D4 and then black
plays D5
black has to be okay with white going
going E5 and that is a direct
transposition to the advanced variation
of the French defense and I'll show you
the actual way that it transposes
afterward now you might say but from
White's perspective what if I don't play
the advance against the French and there
is an alternative to the movie five for
players like that like I don't play the
advanced French and we don't I don't
recommend it in the speed run
so if our opponent plays D5 which he
just did
we have a totally viable alternative in
fact this alternative is recommended in
the sort of elephant Bible that I've
been using to educate uh myself and
everybody else about the proper Theory
and of course the move
is e takes D5 we just take the pawn on
D5
I think white is considered to be
slightly better in the resulting
position black takes back with the queen
which is interesting this transposes to
a position that could also occur if
black would play the main move D5 okay
if black plays D5 here we take it the
queen takes we play D4
and in that position black can't play
the move E6
and then presumably we would play Knight
F3
and we would reach exactly the same
position from the game assuming that we
would play Knight F3 here which we will
of course the alternative is to take
back with the e-pawn that frequently
reaches uh an isolated Queen Pawn
structure I'll talk a little bit about
the theory behind that variation after
the game and I'll show you how white
achieves a small but very pleasant
Advantage Queen takes D5 is an entirely
different kettle of fish the pawn
structure is totally different and this
move has as this line has nothing to do
with e takes D5 they could not be less
related okay so next step of course is
to develop our Knight to F3 this is a
move we know we want to play
and black plays Knight F6 I love facing
this line because my recommendation
against it is rather sexy if I may say
so myself
does anybody know
what my recommended move is against
Knight F6 this is an incredibly
dangerous move
this is a move that
can yield a quick victory
if black is not precise but you should
also not play this move in the hope that
you get a quick win
that should not be your only goal in
playing this move but there's nothing
wrong with playing tricky lines if you
don't sacrifice on objective quality
this move happens to be one of those
rare lines where it is a incredibly
dangerous and B even if black plays the
best moves you are still fighting quite
seriously for an advantage and I'm
talking about the move Knight to A3 as
many of you are indicating this is
impressive a lot of you know this move
now I've talked about this idea before
in the con in in the general context of
the elephant we might have even faced
this line before
Knight A3 is a typical allopin
developing move the Knight is obviously
heading for P5 and what makes this
maneuver you know probable in the
elephant is the fact that black often
has the Queen on D5 which is on a
forkable square so so Knight B5 comes
with the tremendous threat of Knight C7
but that's not the only path that the
Knight can take and our opponent
responds correctly with A6
there is another path that the Knight
can take and in fact we will take this
path because black has prevented Knight
D5 the moment A6 is played a different
forkable Square becomes available and
that's the B6 Square so we want to play
Knight A3 to C4 this is better than
going Bishop to C4
because after Bishop C4 the Knight
starts complaining and saying hey you
you've taken away my only aggressive
square and then you're gonna have to
tuck the Knight away on C2 and that's
not particularly appealing also the
bishop on C4 can later on be easily
chased Away by the move B7 B5 so it's a
classic one militis Knight C4 is a much
more sustainable variation
and there's a lot of theory in this
position there there's a lot to know
here
but let's see what our opponent chooses
the best move for black to my knowledge
is Knight B8 to D7 developing and
protecting the Beast the B6 Square
but a lot of people here I think most
people online they tend to drop their
Queen back to date of course uh
conceivably black could also blunder the
fork and play a move like B5 and just
sort of assume that we're trying to drop
the Knight back to E3
but let's see by the way although black
has sidestepped the sort of first
category of Tricks where often black
just automatically takes on D4 and after
Knight B5 the position becomes extremely
dangerous
but we're not out of Tricks yet Queen d8
okay so that that's I think what we
mostly face
so let me think about this for a second
I'm trying to remember myself what the
what the move is here
huh okay let's think about this
okay I think we should keep developing
our pieces
and I think the important thing to
understand
here
is that B5 in and of itself is not a
dangerous move
if black plays B5 our Knight has a very
nice spot parking spot in the center on
E5 and remember that if black bites off
more than they can chew
this A6 B5 construction if you play the
real Lopez this is true in a lot of
openings can be targeted with the
response a2a4 chipping away at Black's
Pawn chain and when your opponent pushes
a lot of Pawns without pieces supporting
them attacking the pawn chain with your
own pawns can be an incredibly effective
way of causing your opponent's position
to collapse so the upshot is that we are
not afraid of black playing B5 we can
safely continue developing our pieces so
let's identify a piece that can be
nicely developed I'm looking at the dark
Square Bishop generally my preference is
to develop the side of the board on
which you're gonna Castle so that you
don't keep your king in the center for
too long where should the bishop go well
between E2 and D3 it seems to me that D3
is the more active Square because black
is probably going to Castle kingside one
day and we want to be aiming at that H7
Pawn also I don't love the fact that the
Queens are staring at each other I want
to have the power to take the pawn on C5
which we're very likely to do by the way
and not not have to worry about a queen
trade
white is more actively developed here so
all things held equal a queen trade
would be in Black's favor it would
diminish some of our pressure
Bishop E7 our opponent also develops
another nice little byproduct of Bishop
D3 is that now we can play the move D
take C5 and we can win a Tempo I'm not
saying we will play that move but if we
do we we essentially Force the dark
squared Bishop to move two times it just
moved out to E7 and then it will have to
move again to recapture the pawn this is
a common trick also in the Queen's
Gambit uh decline I'll show you a
different application of the same idea
where you wait for your opponent to
develop a piece and then you capture a
certain Pawn they can be recaptured by
the piece that just developed
okay let's continue developing obviously
we should Castle we should get our King
out of the center first and foremost
and again we're not spending a Tempo on
the Move A4 which would be a totally
viable positional move we might even
play it if black castles but I'm I'm
really not concerned about B5 in in a
way I want black to play B5 because it's
so so weakening
okay and we've got many ways in which we
could fight for the advantage here
Black's position I will say is a lot
more dangerous than it seems I think
we're only a couple of moves away
potentially from developing a decisive
attack
so what do I see when I look at this
fish well
we should begin by identifying sort of
our area of superiority why is white
better here where are we going to try to
attack well there's sort of two areas
that I'm looking at
the first is of course the king side our
Bishop is aiming at H7 we've got the
precursor for some great gift ideas
we've got a knight that can hop into G5
our queen of course later on can move
into H5 so we've got a lot of pieces
that in the right circumstances could
quickly launch into a king side attack
black on the other hand is quite
deficient developmentally speaking you
know none of Black's Queen side pieces
are out furthermore
the bishop on C8 is hammed in by his own
Pawn on E6 so what do we know about
playing
in a situation where you are developed a
lot more actively and you have a lead in
development what is the sort of General
prescription in those situations well
the first step is often to open the
center that's what we're taught when you
open the center the effect of better
development is easier to exploit and to
transform into a direct attack or
initiative
so from the sort of principled approach
the move that I would be thinking about
here is just to play D not D5 well D5
blunder is the pawn but I think we
should just take on C5 and I think we
should open the D file I think we should
open the default and then quickly try to
get a rook to that file in order to
start creating threats against Black's
passive pieces and in particular Black's
Queen so I think it's a perfect
opportunity to take on C5 open up the
center and try to use that open Center
to really press on black before he's
able to complete his development
now what's the best way of getting a
rook to D1 where should we put our Queen
this is perhaps a counter-intuitive
question some of you might say oh let's
put it on C2 and let's build a battery
against the H7 punter remember a battery
where the queen is in front of the
bishop is a lot more effective when the
bishop is in front of the queen it's
just toothless right because all this
battery would be doing is attacking H7
the queen would be hamstrung by the
bishop it doesn't make any sense
right like Steph Curry should be
handling the ball not freaking you know
I'm trying to think of a Warriors player
who most people on YouTube will know
some you know bench player the queen
should be in front which means what we
should do here is play Queen D1 to E2
now you might look at this and say am I
crazy Queen E4 is not possible the
Knight defends that square but we're
doing things for the long run you don't
make every move just because on the next
move you want to achieve your main idea
the Knight might eventually leave F6 in
fact we might force it out of F6 because
presumably we're going to develop the
dark squared Bishop to G5 and the move
Queen E4 is something we definitely want
to keep in our pockets also the queen on
E2 is just generally a good Beast it's
just in the center pieces in the center
are good
so Queenie 2 is a lot more
dangerous for black than Queen C2 Knight
bd7 okay our opponent is playing well
I think that we should complete our
developing well our idea with Rook to D1
alternatively we could also bring our
Bishop out first we could play Bishop F4
or Bishop G5 but I don't see a reason
for us to commit I think we should start
with Rook D1 that's just a great move
because it x-rays the queen and it puts
more pressure in the center Queen C7
okay our opponent is not not breaking
under that pressure
well
now I think is the perfect opportunity
for us to complete our development
and play the move
Bishop to G5
and put pressure
I'm using that word a lot but that's
what we're doing put pressure on the
Knight on F6
so let's get our Bishop out to G5
and one idea that you should sort of
keep in your mental directory of ideas
is to maneuver the bishop back to G3
Bishop H4 and Bishop G3 you might
associate that maneuver with necessity
right when your opponent plays H6 which
by the way is not unlikely although
probably a mistake you kind of go there
because you have to here we would go
there because we want to
and because that Queen on C7 is out of
good squares but our opponent plays B5
where should the Knight go well we
already know where the Knight should go
we've already talked about this and
there's no reason for us to deviate the
Knight of course should move to E5
just because black has a knight on D7
doesn't mean we change our plans Knight
takes E5 Knight takes E5 we have enough
Defenders on that square
and notice that if that trade happens we
will then be threatening to take the
Knight on F6 and Force black to
recapture with a pawn which could be a
precursor to some sort of checkmating
idea Our Queen could then move into G4
or to H5 or to E4
potentially so
I think our pressure has reached kind of
an apex and we should start looking very
actively for tactics I think black can
defend but it's not easy like
you know a GM here with black would
definitely find the way to defend but
when you put this amount of pressure on
you know someone in the 16 1700 range as
we've discussed many times blunders tend
to creep in in these types of situations
yeah blunders happen precisely when
there's a lot to keep track of and you
start getting overwhelmed and this is
the style of play that I'm advocating
but our opponent is not buckling Under
Pressure this is very good stuff by
black okay
so
what we're going to have to do
is convert our advantage right we put
all this pressure in the center but I
think our opponent has played this
perfectly
there is a tactic available in this
position as a consequence of which we
went upon not only do we want to
probably Force the game into an end game
and this might not seem like the you
know sexiest alternative imaginable but
this is just what you do when your
opponent plays well you can't always get
everything you want all the time
now we start by trading Knights on D7
Knight takes D7
and actually we're not going to rush
into this tactical operation because yes
this wins a pod but this also uh gives
up the bishop pair so it's not all
totally one-sided
as you might notice the Rook is x-raying
the night the Knight is what's called
a type 2 undefended piece which means
it's only protected by one other piece
you should still be paying attention to
it yeah this is a classic idea Bishop
takes H7
then Queen E2 to D3 and we pick up the
Knight and as a result we're up a pawn
the the issue though is that if we do
that if you keep calculating right
Bishop H7 I can't draw that arrow king
H7 Queen D3 let's say the king moves
back we take the Knight after the trade
black is the bishop pair and Black's
Bishop Bishops are very well placed so I
would say that white is slightly better
in that end game but
if black plays well you know they should
be able to hold the draw
now there's another option here from
White's perspective which is to go
Bishop back to H4 the move that I
indicated before
and still this idea of traveling to G3
with the bishop can be quite effective
because the queen has to keep contact
with the Knight and if we move our
Bishop away from G5 there are some Greek
gift sacrifice ideas so Bishop H4 would
be a viable alternative but I think it
is more consistent with our general
strategy to play Bishop takes H7 Chuck I
think we should play it just because it
signifies a nice payoff
to our middle game play this is like the
natural conclusion of the way in which
we've played the middle game might not
be what you're looking for but you have
to know how to win end games up a pawn
right you can't win every game with a
middle game attack and neither can I
so we're gonna try to convert that pawn
in that resulting end game
I sure as hell try yeah
it's like the One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest quote but I I think but I tried God
damn it
this by the way is a tactical concept
that you should all be familiar with
just the notion of taking on H7 and when
I say this from White's perspective
obviously this also applies for black
like Bishop takes H2 you force the king
onto a vulnerable a checkable square and
then you move your queen to some Square
where it Forks another piece that's
often on the other side of the board in
this case on in the center on D7
okay we can pre-move
Queen design we're not going to we have
plenty of time I actually disabled
Primos
yeah this is a grind this this game I
was expecting
to be honest that our opening would just
yield
a crushing attack but no
we're gonna have to grind it out in an
end game
yes Mr ayoi
okay
well our opponent is thinking and he's
doing a great job honestly but by
thinking in this position I think a lot
of people with black would just
automatically take on D7
and probably that is the best move but
there is an alternative and our opponent
does play the alternative Queen C7 to
b60 decides to keep the Queens on the
board
and our Queen may look like the
strongest piece but in fact it is our
most vulnerable piece because if black
plays on the next move the move Bishop
B7 to D5 Our Queen is locked on black
side of the board and then Rook to A7
will trap the queen so we need to move
our Queen back and we need to do it such
that the F2 Pawn is protected so our our
only move here is to drop the queen back
to D2 We are not afraid of Bishop takes
F3 why are we not afraid of it because
white black has no pieces left this is a
very common mistake I mean I think most
people under 1500 would probably take on
F3 here I think that would be a very
serious mistake because we are still up
a pawn
and in fact as a result of this trade
the G file opens who stands to benefit
from that well we have the classic idea
of moving the king into the corner and
then playing Rook G1 and orchestrating a
furious attack against black skin
so the less minor pieces there are the
less
you know the less important these
structural damages are because black has
no pieces with which to attack white
skating there's no Knight to stick on H4
like we did in the in the last game the
rosalimo game
okay F6
so this forces our Bishop to make a
decision and make a decision we will I
think the decision is quite obvious our
overarching strategy here with white
what should it be well it should be to
simplify right we are up a pawn so
simplification is to our liking
especially when we can trade one of
Black's good pieces and so kind of a
no-brainer type of move here's Bishop
back to E3
and simplification is much more
important than preserving like the
Cosmetic purity of our Pawn structure
you might say oh well after Bishop takes
E3 Queen takes E3 after the trade well
we have an isolated Pawn I don't care
about that in an end game isolated pawns
aren't bad at all because they often
can't be attacked and we're gonna
automatically take with the queen here
trades are good
also I kind of want to play an end game
so I can we haven't had a lot of end
games so I really want to be able to
talk about end game conversion we will
have to play a little bit faster our
opponent keeps Queens on the board and
this is obviously not an easy conversion
task
so okay obviously the the
annoying bit about converting this
consists in Black's piece activity black
has this battery and it's aiming at our
Knight and otherwise we would obviously
play the move Knight to D4 God forbid
don't play that now you get mated on G2
so our Rook for the time being is or
sorry our night for the time being is
somewhat immobilized it's not totally
immobilized if necessary we can drop the
Knight back to E1 and perhaps push our
Pawn out to F3 and try to blunt black
spatter in fact I think that's a great
positional idea to play 91 and then F3
and then I can Circle back around into
the center with Knight to the D3 but
that competes quite strongly with an
alternative there is only one open file
you know what to do and there's only one
open file you want to be the one to
control it so the alternative to me is
to play the move Rook to D2 and to stack
the Rooks on the D file but I want us to
solve immediately the main problem in
our position which of course is the fact
that the Knight can't really participate
in society and from a psychological
standpoint it's always unpleasant to
your opponent when you are are sort of
constantly reacting to your opponent's
main ideas right he's putting his eggs
in this basket and we're trying to you
know break the basket with the move F3
now why are we not afraid of playing F3
again black has no dark squared Bishop
if there was a dark squared Bishop
sitting on E7 it would be Unthinkable to
play three because Bishop C5 would win
the queen with no dark squared Bishop we
can very safely play the move F3 and I'm
not worried Our Queen is protecting this
diagonal we're not moving Our Queen
anytime soon
yeah great play by our opponent this is
a super high level game
black should probably take the open file
with Rook a to d8 and remember the peace
threshold rule when you are up a piece
or more
simplification becomes essentially your
top priority in the sense that it often
is worth to make some concessions in the
name of simplification but when you are
up two pawns or one Pawn simplification
is often good but not good to the point
where you want to simplify at the cost
of making those same concessions so
after Rook Ada a common mistake would be
to take that rook and say well I'm
training Rooks I'm making progress but
it's not worth giving up the only open
file just to trade a pair of Rooks
hopefully that makes
high level sense Rook takes D Rook takes
d8 our pieces are not active enough to
sustain another
you know major weakness or major artery
so after Rook 88 what I like is just to
continue our
re-re shuffling with Knight E1 to D3
there's a very juicy square that I've
already noticed and that's the C5 Square
imagine putting a knight on C5 and then
perhaps supporting it with the move B4
that's a very nice Outpost
and then we can slowly start working on
getting control of the D file
okay Rook FDA
well I don't see a reason for us to take
long on this move let's go Knight to D3
an alternative would be to play this
move Rook to D3 trying to combine two
ideas in one
where you're going for the old idea of
doubling Rooks but you're also trying to
trade on your own terms should black
take the Rook you're going to take back
with a knight and continue the other
maneuver but this is a little bit too
subtle for me let's go Knight T3
well no I liked Knight E1 because of the
F3 concept but I also like as a bonus
that the Knight of C5 the best move for
black
would probably be
to play Rook a to C8 but that's and he
plays it okay
well the Fight Continues
hmm
all right so again I see a couple of
options for us
one option is to play a move like H4 and
try to run this Pawn up to H6 and soften
up Black's Pawn chain that's one option
but I want to no but before blender is
the a lot of you are suggesting before
forgetting that the C3 Pawn will be
hanging
so I like the idea of playing before but
we need to prepare it and we often moves
should be prepared
directly right the way to prepare B4 is
not going to win you any beauty prizes
or Brilliance prizes
but some moves like this can be the most
annoying to face and the most effective
Rook a to C1
well we don't need to defend the C3 Pawn
but we will if we played before and once
we get the Knight C5 we will thank
ourselves for playing this Preparatory
move the Rook is complaining it's like
do I really need to be doing this yes
you do
and it's also not committal now what I
like about this move is it's totally
non-committal if black does something we
need to change our plans no worries we
put a rook on C1 that doesn't harm our
position in any way a good alternative
to this move would have been to drop the
Knight back to F2 and start getting
Rooks off the board
but I want us to at least torture our
opponent with the prospect of going B4
is E4 not dangerous well if you actually
calculate it E4 we play F takes E4
what's the problem I don't get what the
problem is
about the movie four I mean if black
takes to the queen that absolutely trade
all the pieces this is good for us
you know big deal the Knight will be
hanging at the end of the line we have
plenty of squares for the night we can
move it to F4 we could move it maybe to
B4
so yeah the bishop has more air true but
you're not going to prevent everything
right remember that we are a papon so
all things held equal trades are good
for us
even if they come with a small price tag
Rook to D6 another great move our
opponent and this is a great move
because in the event of before black now
doubles Rooks on the D file and we just
aren't in time to play Knight C5 because
the Rook under one hangs
well I think that
the outline the scenario that I outlined
has come to fruition where we need to
change our plans at the drop of a hat
we will no longer be able to play before
in like a good version
so we have a couple of options in lieu
of that we can play Knight F2 write that
old idea but I don't think we need to
open up the D file immediately I think
it would make sense for us to double
Rooks on the D file and then move the
Knight away from D3
okay
uh so let's go Rook D2
I'm anticipating Rook C to d8 then we
will play Rook C to D1
and at that point the tension will have
reached kind of an apex and presumably
we will then want to move the Knight
away from D3 and get all four Rooks off
the board in such a way that we don't
also like blunder upon or run into some
fork or allow some attack
so okay our opponent taking taking time
yep okay well Rook cd1 we can play
quickly
now notice something well okay let's
wait for the move let's wait for the
move
what is our next move likely to be well
unless black does so probably the best
move here is Queen C4
that's a very very high level move
that's a very high level move because it
okay well what's interesting is that's
actually a blunder
um I did that deliberately
it is a blunder
it is a it is a good move from a
positional standpoint but it is a
blunder tactically how do I know that
it's a blunder
this doesn't mean anything by the way
there is I let's not fall prey to
confirmation bias there is a chance our
opponent was listening but there's also
a chance that he came up with this
independently why is it a blunder well
anytime you've got pieces staring at
each other on an open file
through the lens of another piece right
that is a discovered attack waiting to
be played right there's a knight on D3
like this we control the lever right we
can move the Knight whenever we want to
and what I'm seeing is that the move
Queen C4 relinquishes Black's defense on
the D6 Rook it is now a type 2
undefended piece it's only protected by
one other piece and it is stared at by
two other pieces both Rooks are staring
at the Rook on D6 all of this should
lead you
to the very pretty tactic Knight takes
E5 the reason we needed the black queen
to move away from C6
was that with the queen on C6 Knight
takes C5 black would just recapture and
he would have sufficient Defenders on
The Rook now very important detail what
do we do if black takes the Rook on D2
well what do we do
and you might get excited and grab the
queen here that would be a grave error
because black takes the Rook on D1 Queen
disease is what I call it and then black
takes the Knight on C4 and black has a
kingdom and a horse for the queen black
has two Rooks and a bishop that's way
too much material so obviously
you should play Rook takes D2 and here's
the second important bit if the black
Rook on d8 were defended let's say the
bishop wasn't on B7 it was on E7 this
whole procedure would not work because
in this position black would take on E5
and that's it The Rook would be defended
so when I was taking on E5 it was
critical not only that The Rook on D6
was unprotected but that it's
counterpart on d8 was also undefended
there were a lot of moving parts to
account for here
the game is not over black loses the
second Pawn at this point it's just a
matter of converting carefully but we
still have a lot of work to do
okay
there's a lot of nuance to these
tactical operations and ideas
and
when you see a tactic like this it's
important to realize like what are the
underlying themes that's what allows you
to find moves like this during the game
and what's easy to miss about it okay so
here clearly we should take the low
hanging fruit
and we should trade Rooks
and now our Knight is hanging we should
decide where to put it Knight to G6
would be a blunder that would blunder
the Knight one of the most common types
of blunders in you know Queen and Knight
versus queen and Bishop positions is of
course blundering your extra your minor
piece knight G6 puts the Knight on a
super vulnerable square and after Queen
to D1 check black steps back to C2
forking the king in the night that's the
best way to lose so let's keep it safe
and keep it tight and play Knight C3 you
want to keep it very defense especially
if you're low on time you want to make
sure that your pieces protect each other
and we have an extra Pawn on both sides
of the board so how are we actually
going to win this well we're going to
trade Queens if we have the opportunity
to do so we're not going to try to force
it we're certainly not going to
sacrifice a pawn in order to trade
Queens but if a good opportunity
presents itself we will jump at it
generally assuming the Queens are gonna
stay on the board our strategy is to
just create a past pawn and push it
right that's the stock winning plan in
so many different types of end games and
just because there are Queens on the
board doesn't mean it's an exception to
the rule so what's the easiest pass bond
to create well if you look at both sides
of the board carefully
there is a past Pawn that's waiting to
be created we start with the move B3 and
then we push the pawn through to C4 not
immediately but we use our Queen to pry
The Black Queen off of D5 and to prepare
C4
that's that's step one step one is to
play the move C4
we should also consider bringing the
king up to F2 where it's a little bit
safer it's not subject to back ring
checks but let's not jump the gun let's
wait for Black's move
King f8 well
and that loses on the spot we made a
mental note to ourselves if we get a
queen trade opportunity
in a good set of circumstances we do it
because it's just easier to win this end
game with no queens and we just did
right when you make these mental notes
to yourself you're just far more likely
to see opportunities when they arise
there's the trade of Queens okay so here
the win is very straightforward our
general plan has not changed we will
still create a past pawn and promote it
and maybe even create another one on the
other side of the board but with the
Queens off the board it has become more
important to be patient right rather
than playing C4 immediately let's begin
by bringing our King all the way up to
the center and there is a sort of
ticking clock here figuratively because
we don't want to allow Black's King to
get overly active right we want to bring
our King up to D4
uh in a way that restricts the activity
of its counterpart and that's why there
is no time to waste we go King F2
straight away
oh we had a very nice move there
actually
let me think about this for a second we
there's a cool idea in lieu of this but
we're gonna play it simple and now of
course King to D4 anytime you have a
situation like this where your king
defends a minor piece be very careful
that your opponent can't use a pawn to
dislodge your king I see blunders like
this all the time if black had a Pawn on
E7 right now black would have the move
E5 check and we would lose our Knight
okay black is collapsing obviously
that's another blunder now we're three
pawns up and there's no reason that we
need to give up any of our Pawns
a nice way to defend it an elegant way
to defend it is to bring the Knight back
to B4
and that's it we create a past Pawn we
can play A4 we can play C4 black resigns
it was a very nice meeting
okay I lost my lid to the iced tea
okay
let's go over it quickly
I'm gonna bring out the alopin Bible so
I can give you a little bit of context
on the theory here
so
so E5 transposes to the advanced Fetch
and if you are an advanced French player
then by all means you can avoid a lot of
theory by playing E5 or you can
transition it into Theory you already
know but I am gearing this toward people
who don't play the advanced French and I
keep saying what is the advanced French
well that's the French is E6 and the
advanced variation is E5 which I do
recommend by the way but after C5 as you
may know I recommend the nimsovich
variation which is Knight G1 to F3 and
I've had plenty of speedrun games
that go that have went like this if you
play the main move C3 then this is
indeed the advanced French it's the same
exact position
as after four E5 in the album and I'm
clicking actually at these two different
spots and as you can see the position is
not changing
okay
so the the allopin-esque move is e takes
D5 and here black has a fork in the road
let's take a quick look at e takes D5
I'm going to give you a little bit of
context here for how
uh califman recommends that white should
play
it's page 128 and of course I know but I
I want to confirm
okay
so why is it likely
that this reaches an isolated Queen Pawn
structure well the reason is because
white can reach the iqp structure
anytime they want we can play D takes C5
and after Bishop takes E5 there is an
isolated Queen Pawn on D5 now in the
alapin you often play with the isolated
Queen pun here you are playing against
it and the great thing about the pawn on
C3 is that it controls the square in
front of the pawn so yes the Knight
can't move out to C3 but the pawn is
actually a great asset here because it
keeps the pawn confined on D5 but you
don't want to take on C5 straight away
you want to do it at a more opportune
moment
yeah so you want to start by playing
Knight to F3
and here most of the time
you get a little bit of development a
black has a couple of moves here
that I can show you if black plays
um if black plays
C4
no first of all if black develops the
dark squared Bishop who can tell me what
we would do in this situation let's see
who paid attention to something that I
said during the game the moment black
plays Bishop to D6 or Bishop D7 now we
take on C5 and we win a Tempo we force
the bishop to move twice
and here we got a big development
Advantage we play Bishop B5 check
and already black is in some trouble
um if black plays Knight C6
then we transpose into a line that I'll
show you through a different move order
if black plays Bishop D7 though we can
already snap off the pawn on D5 Queen
takes D5
um
and after Queen well Bishop takes B5 we
play here and we're up a full Pawn
Queen D3 is not dangerous because we
have this check and black is getting
massacred
so here there's the check on E7 it
appears to win a piece because black
defends the bishop but the bishop can
drop back to E2
and black has insufficient compensation
for the pawn queen D1
Knight C6 castles black and Castle Queen
side this is the game Ginsburg against
ryoka Buenos Aires 1993.
Bishop D3 Black's pieces have been
deployed actively
but he can hardly prove to have
sufficient compensation for the pawn
because white has no weaknesses in his
position it's like 0.6 here
uh so that's uh what to do in the event
the black moves the dark skirt Bishop
if flag plays C4 then the response here
is of course to play B3 cutting into
this Pawn
and if black plays B5 this you should
already know from previous speedrun
games how do you keep attacking this
Pawn chain well you play the typical
move A4 and you want to do this quickly
because if black plays A6 after a b
black loses is The Rook on A8 is
unprotected right notice that if Black's
Bishop was on B7 all of this would have
worked out
so the main move here by far is Knight
to F6
um and here you give a nice little check
on B5 developing with tempo
pretty straightforward
and there's another fork in the road
here
there's another fork in the road there
is the move Knight to C6
and then even of Knight to C6
we Castle
and you do the same thing eventually
black is going to have to develop his
Bishop out to E7 and the moment that
they do that you take on C5
then the other Bishop comes out to G5
and this is a very unpleasant position
for black because if black simply
castles well of course we take on F6 and
black has zero compensation for the pawn
so blackcast2 play a move like Bishop to
E6 which is quite passive if black plays
Bishop back to E7
who can tell me where this Knight
ultimately belongs that night on B1
what is its ultimate destination Square
it's B3 yeah we want the Knight to be
three
yb3 because again we're ultimately
heading for D4 to blockade the isolated
Queen pawn and white is in fact
dominating the square in front of the
pawn
if black plays H6 we don't normally
trade this bishop unless we win the D5
Pawn
okay Bishop G4 rookie one
rookie 8 H3
and after Bishop H5 black lost the pawn
takes takes
so you can see how often black is unable
to keep the pawn protected
this is just one illustrative line
what else is there so if black plays
Bishop to E6 in this position
then white again does the same thing
Knight beta D2 castles Knight to B3
Bishop to B6
and Knight B to T4 and white is slightly
better
white is slightly better I mean Rook to
E1 is coming next Califon gives the line
Rook C8 rookie one Bishop to G4
Bishop takes C6
and H3
and here you are transitioning the
advantage from
isolated Queen Pawn to an attack against
Black's King Bishop H5 Knight F5
threatening a fork on E7
King h8 rookie five
Bishop C7 rookie seven
and situation is very unpleasant for
black you can see how active this is
they give the line Bishop G6
Bishop takes F6
if gf6 are beautiful
Queen D4
Bishop F5 Queen F6 Knight G5 look at
this line
now what is white threatening in this
position white is threatening to take
the bishop and mate on H7
Bishop G6 Knight to E6 the showstopper
the show stopper
fe6 mate
it's over black has to give away no
black can't even black it just gets
mated
uh so this is their main line actually
how cool is that
so that's how dangerous these positions
are for black it's not just positional
pressure you can actually transform it
into an attack
so the last thing I'd like to show
is the main line
which uh is
which is Knight to C6 Bishop B5 and now
Bishop to D6 largely it's the same thing
takes takes castles now if Knight F6
then
then Bishop G5 and we get a very similar
position to what we looked at if 97
then Knight bd2
castles
and again it's the same deal Knight to
B3
and white is slightly better Bishop D6
they recommend Bishop back to D3 in
order to set up an attack on H7
and set a trap if Bishop G4 there is the
classic Bishop H7 and Knight G5 picking
up the bishop so basically White's idea
in this line is to wait for black to
develop his Dark Sword bishop and then
take on C5 then reposition the Knight to
B3 and sometimes even to D4 and based on
what black does either accumulate pieces
in the center or bring the bishop back
to D3 or as you saw in that first line
develop a direct attack against Plex
King so there's so much more to talk
about in this line but this is just a
very basic a very basic Rundown
okay now we get to the game Queen takes
D5
so here after Knight F3 Knight F6 there
are multiple
possible moves I really like the move
Knight A3
um and
if black plays C takes D4 then of course
you go Knight B5
and you know conceivably some games end
like this this is just a fork but most
people who look at this position for the
first time with black they end up
dropping the queen back and after Queen
takes D4 black is in huge trouble in
this position
why is blocking huge trouble because if
you look at this position I mean White's
Knights are ridiculously active there's
a fork threat on C7 the bishop is
terrible and white just has like an
overwhelming initiative the knights
coming into D6
and once the Knight comes into D6 I mean
just look at this position that the
lights dark squares the king is stranded
it's like plus two already
just because the Queens are off the
board does not mean that white doesn't
have a furious initiative he does
in this position black is best advised
to play this move Knight A6
but uh after n b takes D4 is still very
unpleasant for black I actually won a
game here very recently
um I won a game here very very recently
with white and it was a completely
one-sided game it was in the US Open
it was in the US Open
and I can show you
I was against the GM
and it wasn't even close
it was not even close
oh but it was a slightly different line
no it was not it was the same one
nice
now black played a different move
instead of C takes D4 but you'll get the
point
it's much the same ideas
this is to show you that I do in fact
practice what I preach
okay this is in the recent tournament
that I played well I choose a GM
okay
Bellagio plays Knight C6
Bishop to E3
in this particular line you don't want
to rush Knight B5 you actually want to
go here first you wait for CD and now
you go on ip5 why so that the Knight can
then recapture on D4 and have a nice
Escape Route
my opponent just kind of plays natural
moves but this type of position is just
horrible for black because just no good
way to develop the light squared bishop
and look at how nicely White's pieces
are positioned and my play is so natural
95 rookie one
takes takes Queen F3
Queen F4 x-raying
The Rook on B8 Knight T5 over to H4
bring the other Rook into the game now
black collapses F6 Knight back to G4 and
already Black's position is terrible but
he blunders with Queen E7 who can tell
me
how I finish the game in this very
position he resigns in two moves
well Balaji is a mayor I mean he was
born in the U.S
Knight takes H6 very nice lpdo loose
pieces drop off
Queen G3 Bang
goodbye Rook
good by night game is over
now this is a slightly idealized game he
didn't play too well but still
you know this line of the elephant is
incredibly dangerous for black
yeah just a disgusting game one of my
better alopin wins actually
and I've been a couple gyms in the
elephant so
it's a venomous opening at every level
okay
so
as we were discussing CD Knight B5
Knight A6 Knight B takes D4
and if black plays the move E5 here it's
very important to know what to do
because if you're looking at this for
the first time you might say oh well I
have to move my knight and then black
can take the queen and force my king to
move
no no no you give a check
and after Bishop D7 you play this
classic move Queen E2 pinning the pawn
and attacking the pawn
and in the event of takes takes I mean
you can see how dangerous this is for
black the king is stranded and if black
plays E4 we don't have to react which is
Castle
and then Rook D1 is coming I mean the
Knight is a monster it's unassailable
the Knight on B5 is unassailable because
when the Knight comes out to A6 black
can no longer play Pawn A6
this by the way also is an idea in the
jababa London
get a very similar concept
where
basically in certain variations
um in certain variations
for example let me think
what did Ortiz play against me
Ortiz play against me in certain
variations okay the bottom line is like
you go
you go Knight B5 and you get this
monster Knight on B5 because it can't be
can't be attacked and it can be easily
supported with a pawn so just remember
this construction when the opponent's
Knight comes out to A6 or H6 you can put
a knight on the Square diagonal to it
and it cannot be attacked by a pawn
so
you know in the game our opponent plays
the correct move A6
um you can see how dangerous C takes D4
is
now we get the Knight into C4 and queen
d8 is a mistake this is uh clearly
better for white the only way for black
to keep something resembling equality is
nbd7
and here the move that kalifman
recommends is actually A4
and I think I've already analyzed this
in a previous speedrun game white is
slightly better I think we'll get
another chance probably to play this
exact line so here I would like to stick
to what our opponent played and really
talk about the continuation of the game
because among Club players I think Queen
d8 is going to be a more common move
okay so we get our Bishop out to the
most active squared to the square D3
black develops we develop black develops
and we took this opportunity to take on
C5 and make black lose a tempo now he
played the move Queen E2
creating space for The Rook to move into
D1 Knight bd7
and I actually think that Rook D1
was uh not the best way to play I think
given how the game continued
I think it would have been a better idea
a more prudent idea
to at this point
either prevent B5 with A4 I think this
would have been a good moment to do it
because of course black can play B6 and
now most importantly get this bishop out
to F4
I feel like Bishop F4
would have been a more unpleasant move
because it deprives the queen of the C7
square and in the game I kind of
underestimated the impact of black
bringing the queen to C7
of course if black plays B5 here we can
do the same thing we did in the game and
move the Knight to E5
but if you think about it after Bishop
B7 Rook a D1 The Black Queen doesn't
have the C7 Square anymore obviously
we just play Knight takes D7
if Queen takes Bishop then we take the
other bishop and here you have the
classic
discovery on H7 so I think with or
without A4
we should have developed the bishop to
F4 rather than G5
in the game we played Rook D1 we allowed
the queen to occupy the square
still maybe A4 would have been better
because B5 is is a rather
good idea for black
so we played here B5 here here but I can
see that we actually all play the engine
moves
Knight D7 Knight D7 and we cash in our
advantage with Bishop takes H7 check
takes and according to the engine it is
a 0.3.4 Advantage for white so black
should be able to hold a draw but black
is not having any fun here
and I think we won the game very
smoothly F6 might be a slight inaccuracy
because it weakens the king side pawns
how would I defend this for black I
would probably play a move like B4 and
try to orchestrate some Queen side
counter play
but still after take Stakes Queen E2
white is up a pawn
and we're controlling the d8 square
and um you know white has I think pretty
decent chances to convert you can
analyze a position like this with an
engine if you want to learn more about
these types of structures but I'm
getting exhausted so we're gonna move to
the end of the game here
um we trade
according to the computer yeah Queen C6
is the best move and now Knight E1 I
really really like I think 91 is
a very important Motif to move the
Knight away
and then bring a pawn up in order to
blunt
uh your opponent's battery
right that's how you want to generalize
this idea you move the Knight away and
then the Knight is replaced by a pawn
and the purpose of that pawn is to
create you know a situation where your
opponent bites on granite
um
I had a game
against Carlson actually in AIM chess
where I did something similar but I
can't find it right now I think you get
the point though I think you get the
point of the move 91.
um
E5
we play F3 we cut into the the battery
and then we bring our Knight into the
game with Knight T3 and of course if
blackhead made some random move we would
have played Knight to C5 and supported
the Knight with the move before but our
opponent was not that Cooperative he
played Rook ac-8 now we've got Rook ac1
again we're trying to go B4 Knight C5
and still our opponent does not
cooperate now it's interesting I had to
refresh because I was disconnected
what's interesting about this situation
is that the engine actually believes
that Black's best chance to make a draw
would have been to play E4
and as a result of the trade
it's a position where the bishop is very
active
and the Knight doesn't have a lot of
good squares and Black's Pawn structure
is pretty healthy so I would say that
it's maybe a 50 50 position 50 chance of
white winning 50 chance of a draw
um but probably this was the the best
bet for black the way he played
um it allowed us to to double Rooks on
the D file
and still the last chance for black
would have been
to actually play a very smart move Queen
back to D7 would have
given us some trouble
because if we move our Knight away then
black wins with Rook takes D2 and it's
important to realize that just because
you win the queen doesn't mean you win
the game in fact here you obviously lose
the game because you lose a lot of
pieces
so if I were playing Black I would go
Queen back to D7 and try to tie down
this Knight prevent the knight from
moving away
now we would have probably brought our
King to the rescue with King F2 and King
E2
maybe this and the moment the queen
moves away we drop our Knight into C5 so
here our plan would have been to bring
the king to E2 and free up the Knight
and try to force as many trades as
possible I think black is in huge
trouble here anyway but our opponent
hastened the process with Queen to C4
Knight takes C5 hopefully this move
makes sense obviously if he takes the
Knight we take twice and we're up in
exchange no no background shenanigans
um and it's important just to reiterate
that The Rook on d8 is undefended
otherwise black would have taken and
here it's important that we're able to
take the Rook with check it's also
important that after here here our King
has looked imagine upon being on F2 Rook
D1 would have been Checkmate so what I'm
trying to say is that these complicated
tactics are always contingent on certain
things being the way they are about the
position you can never take those things
for granted that's why it's so important
to make observations say oh well one
positive byproduct of the move F3 is
that I have a a square for my king I
don't have to worry about background
problems
um yeah maybe black could have also
tried E4 here
uh but that night before is a very
important move you do not want to take
on e4
because suddenly you dig yourself into a
hole and the Knight is lost here you
need to keep your queen on E3 and here
you go night before
and then you trade everything
and then you win a second Pawn
so here this is bad for black
conorab asks why Rook fd1 instead of
Rook 81
[Music]
um
well that was a while ago let me rewind
all the way back the reason we played
Rook fd1 well no we played Rook deal
because it was the only Rook that could
move to D1 at that point
now maybe you're asking about a later
point in the game
no there was no point at which we had a
choice of Rooks to put on a square I
actually took the question seriously I
forgot that we didn't have that choice
it's a good question in general
so in any case after Queen C4 we take a
second Pawn we trade all the Rooks we
move our Knight back and if black had
not allowed the trade of Queens then we
would have won the game by playing a
move like Queen to D4
the trade is easy and if black moves we
would go on King F2 to stop Queen E2 and
then we would have gone C4 and C5 and
ultimately we would have promoted our
Pawn we don't even really need our Pawn
majority on the other side of the board
um so again if you want more practice
converting advantages one thing you can
always do is you can set up a position
like this at home and play it against
the computer I actually highly recommend
it uh if you want to be super diligent
analyze this position with the computer
see how the engine converts the
advantage I mean that's how you learn
right that's how you learn certain types
of conversions it's not everything is
available on YouTube or in a book you
need to get a feel for how to do certain
things in chess and the best way to to
get a feel for stuff is to play it out
and to make mistakes
but after black allowed the queen trade
everything was very easy of course he
blunders a second a third Pawn but if he
didn't do that we would have gone C4 and
again the win is very easy
so thank you all for those new to my
stream I have a YouTube channel we're
slowly building toward 400 000 Subs so
every sub counts and I appreciate it
allowing me to do what I love and what I
think I'm meant to do
bye
[Music]